we're on problem for traditions clothing
stores having a sale shirts that were
regularly priced at $20 are on sale for
17 dollars what is the percentage of the
decrease in the price of the shirts so
what's just the decrease in the price of
the shirts well they've gone from $20 to
$17 so the decrease is three dollars we
have a $3 decrease in the price of the
shirts so what is the percentage of
decrease what we're starting at 20 and
we're decreasing by 3 so the percentage
of a decrease let me write it in a
darker color we're starting at 20 and
we're decreasing it by 3 or decreasing
it by 3 over 20 this is this is the
percent decrease or the fraction
decreased right there and this is going
to be equal to what this is the same
thing I mean we could divide it out if
you if you don't well you might be able
to do that in your head but just to kind
of in case you can't let me just write
it out like this so if I divide 20 into
3 20 does not go into 3 so 20 or you
could say 20 goes into 3 0 times and 0
times 20 is 0 and then I put a decimal
point right there 20 goes into 30 maybe
I should have done this let me do it
over here 20 goes into 3 0 times 0 times
20 is 0 and then let me put a decimal
point like that so I put a decimal there
and then I'll do 3 minus at 0 so I'll
let's take a 3.0 just like that maybe I
shouldn't even write the decimal maybe
I'll write a 30 like that we have the
decimal up here 20 goes into 30 one time
one times 20 is 20 30 minus 20 is 10 and
then bring down another zero this year
right there and 20 goes into 100 five
times 5 times 20 is 100 100 minus 100 is
0 so 3 over 20 can be rewritten as 0.15
and the way another way you could think
about this is 3 twentieths is the same
thing if you're most
by the numerator in the denominator by 5
is the same thing as 15 over 100 right
if I multiply the top and the bottom by
5 which you can always do this the same
thing as 15 over 100 so that's a way you
could have done that in your head saying
oh that's the same thing as point 1 5
and point 1 5 expressed as a percentage
is 15 percent so the correct answer is B
alright problem number 5 which number
equals 2 to the minus 4 powers this is a
bit a little bit of review of exponents
2 to the minus 4 is the same thing as 1
over 2 to the 4th power that's all a
negative exponent does it means 1 over
essentially the base to the positive
exponent and this is just going to be 1
over 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 and
that's what 2 times 2 is 4 times 2 is 8
times 2 is 16 so it's equal to 1 over 16
so that is choice C problem 6
what is 3/4 minus 1/6 so whenever you
add or subtract fractions you have to
find a common denominator a common
denominator and a good common
denominator is the least common multiple
of these two guys or the smallest number
that both of these denominators go into
so the smallest number that both of
these denominators go into is what's 12
right 12 4 goes into 12 three times and
6 goes into 12 two times so let's
rewrite these fractions with 12 as a
denominator so 2 something over 12 minus
something over 12 so how do we rewrite
3/4 as something over 12 well 4 goes
into 12 3 times
so or we could say 3 times 4 is 12 so 3
times 3 will be the other numerator get
9 12 3/4 + 9 12 so the exact same
fraction this is in in kind of the
simplest form or when you've reduced the
numeron denominator as much as you can
but this is a completely equivalent
fraction to go from there to there you
just multiply
by the numerator and the denominator by
3 3 times 3 is 9 3 times 4 is 12 and the
way you can think about it four goes
into 12 three times so just multiply
three times that numerator let's do the
same thing with 1 6 6 goes into 12 two
times so to go from there to there we
have to multiply the six by two so go
from there to whatever this numerator is
we have to multiply that numerator by
two so you stick a 2 right there and now
that we have a common denominator this
becomes a simple problem to work out it
is equal to we have you know 9 out of 12
pieces - 2 out of 12 pieces or whatever
we're talking about or slices of pie so
that's going to be equal to 7 over 12
and that is choice C next problem
problem 7 problem 7 dude in blue again a
salesperson at a clothing store earns a
2% Commission 2% Commission on all sales
how much Commission does the salesperson
earn on a $300 sale well they may turn
2% on that so or you could say 0.02 of
the sales so you can just multiply 300
times
0.02 and you know this is kind of the
way to just do it and I'll maybe give
you a little intuition how you can do
this on your head if you're constrained
for time but the easiest way to think
about it is just multiply 2 times 300 or
2 times 0 is 0
2 times 0 is 0 and 2 times 3 is 6 you
could have done that in your head 2
times 300 is 600 and then you worry
about the decimals so we have 2 spaces
behind the decimal right here right we
have 1/2 so we're going to have to have
two spaces behind the decimal in our
answer so we're going to have to have
one two spaces behind the decimal so the
answer right here is $6 and that is
choice a now way you could have done
this in your head you could have said
look they make he makes a 2% Commission
so for every hundred dollars he makes $2
right 2% is the same thing as 2 out of
100 so every hundred he makes too tall
he sold $300 so that's 300 so that would
also be three times $2 per hundred or
$6.00 whatever whatever is easier for
you to understand that's what you should
do problem number eight I'll do this
just in green some students attend
school 180 of the 365 days in a year
about what part of the year do they
attend school and so the key word here
is about which tells me that they don't
want an exact answer they don't want me
to sit there I mean if I wanted to you
know they attend 180 out of 365 days if
I wanted the exact percentage I would
have to take 365 and divided into 180
with some decimals and I'll get some you
know I could work it out just like I did
the decimal division in the past but it
would take some time and they just want
to know about
so what's 180 over 365 roughly well
what's 180 times 2 we could say you know
180 over 360 and I pick 360 because
that's 180 times 2 that's equal to 50%
this is not that different than this we
just have a small change in the
denominator small relative to how large
that denominator is so the answer here
is 50% and you know if they had a couple
of other choices here like 49% or 51%
then you would have to work this out a
little bit a little bit more detail but
it's pretty clear that 180 over 360 180
over 365 is pretty close to 50% it's
nowhere near 18% or 75% so you can feel
pretty good about this answer if 49%
were one of the choices then I would
have to do a little bit more arithmetic
right here with the division problem
number 9 what is the value of 2 to the
6th times 2 to the 4th divided by 2 to
the fifth
now you could solve each of these powers
2 to the 6th is what it's like 64 you
know it's - it's well - you know you
could you could work out each of these
exponents and then multiply them and
then divide but it would take you
forever so what they
really want you to do years use your
exponent rules so when you multiply two
exponents and they have the same base
let me write it this way 2 to the 6
times 2 to the 4 all of that over 2 to
the 5th what's that equal to so let's
just simplify the numerator first so
I'll keep the denominator the same when
you multiply 2 when you multiply 2 to
exponents with the same base you
essentially can just add the exponents
so the same base is 2 so this is going
to be equal to 2 to the 6 plus 4 or 2 to
the 10th power
now when you divide exponents that have
the same base
you subtract the exponents so this is
going to be equal to 2 to the 10 minus 5
power which is equal to 2 to the 5th and
that's our answer and we look at our
choices we don't see 2 to the 5th so
we're actually going to have to multiply
it out and so 2 to the 5th is 2 times 2
times 2 times 2 times 2 2 times itself 5
times that's what 2 to the 5th means so
what is this 2 times 2 is 4 4 times 2 is
8 8 times 2 is 16 16 times 2 is 32 so
that is our answer
d